OEL AS MURPH MENTIONED OUT
BECAUSE OF AND A ROUGH FIRST
SHIFT HERE FOR THE CAN YOU $1 M,
WILLIAM GOUGHNOR.GLANDER, WITH D
SCHEIFELE, TIED UP.OTING
POOLMAN, SKATING RIGHT INTO
TRAFFIC AS THE JETS NOWOWS.: SCD
OUT.
THE JETS, THEY CONTROL.S TO MYEO
CIRCLE BACAC: KNOW SOMEONE WHO S
MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN TO
KEEP IT A 1-1 GAME.
HÖGLANDER NOW WITH A WRISTER HE
SCORES!AS OUT
BY DEMKO AND, OH, UP
BREAKAWAY, IT IS CONOR RIGHT,
EVERYONE IS GOING OFF AND LOOK
T LINESMAN, HE WAS
RIGHT THERE.
>> John S.: THE JETS, THEY BREAK
TO CENTRE,
INSIDE, OUTSIDE AND JUST
THE CANUCKS 3, THERE IS QUINN
HUGHES, HERE, THE GOOD
FORECHECK, THAT TIME BY DUBOIS,
SPEC-SAVERS, BRINGING YOU THIS
CHALLENGE.
>> John G.: YES, AND BECAUSE KIF
SPUN DEMKO WHO MIGHT HAVE HAD A
CHANCE TO PUSHNDED FOR WHILER, ,
PEARSON NOW, CORNER AND THAT
PASS, DID IT CATCH
WHEN Y
CONNOR CENTERING.
BLOCKED BYUCKS HAVE TO CHANGE TE
OTHER TWO, PEARSON, MYERS, OUT
AHEAD TO CENTRE.
THTH AND WHEN
THEY GOT THE SHOT THERE WAS
ABSOLUW WHO USED TO
DO THAT?
>> John G.: IT THE FORSBERG!
CANUCKS
WIN AND DUBOIS HAD ANN